(audience cheers)
- Wow, thank you so much!
- I don't think I've ever met anyone
with such an interesting career.
Like, you were in boxing
for like 15 years, right?
- Correct.
- Yeah, and first of
all, welcome to the show.
- Thank you so much.
- But also then, like, what...
Like, how did this start?
How did you start boxing?
Why was that a thing for you?
- Well, you know, I'm one of five children
and I have two older brothers.
I know we were talking
about siblings earlier,
and I've always been
really sporty as a kid,
basketball, softball.
But my mom was really girly.
She wanted me to wear dresses
and I'm, like, in trees
and I just wanted to fight
the boys in the neighborhood.
But boxing was something that nobody did
in my family or anything.
And I just really liked
this whole aspect of boxing.
It kind of found me.
And I needed somewhat of an outlet
going through some things as a kid.
- Yeah.
- I got my butt whooped, my first fight,
my first amateur fight, and
it was one of those things,
do I say this isn't for me,
or I wanted to see how
does that not happen again?
So I just honed in on it
and wanted to just
become the best I could.
- Yeah, you're badass.
- Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- Yeah.
How did it go from boxing to acting?
Like, did you always kind
of have a dream for that,
like, secretly?
- You know, I've been asking
myself this question a lot.
Like, how did this happen?
I really don't know.
It just kind of happened, I mean...
- Those are the best things,
though, that you don't...
It just organically happens in life.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm really artistic.
You know, I played the violin
when I was nine years old,
come from a musically inclined family,
and it was, like, something
that I wasn't like,
"I wanna grow up and I
wanna be in Hollywood."
It was like, "That'd be kind of cool.
I want to kind of try it one day."
But I did have this, like,
thing that I used to do
when my mom, when she'd come home,
I'd, like, play around with her, like,
dresses and stuff like that
and come up with these characters.
- Yeah.
- And like, I had these
specific characters.
I would just entertain
my family all the time.
But I'm like, you know, maybe
one day it will find me.
If it's meant for me, it'll find me.
And then it found me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It found me.
- I know, it found you and
you're incredible at both things.
It's such a...
It's just a random career, right?
That, like, not many people have.
That's such a blessing.
I think it's cool to
stand out in that way.
- Absolutely.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Your mom gave you a nickname, right?
- So, my Native American
name is Mequinonoag,
which means "many feathers, many talents."
- Love!
- I guess she kind of
saw what I was gonna do.
- Yeah, I was gonna say, wow.
Nostradamus, I was like,
"She saw that coming."
- Yeah, so, it was actually quite an honor
'cause she saw a lot of things in me
I didn't see in myself as a kid,
and it took a while for me
to kind of get comfortable
where I am now, so I embrace
that name and just...
I stick to it, making sure
I get the best out of myself
no matter what it is, you know?
And I have many talents to...
And many gifts, too, to
share with the world.
- And who knows what else as well?
- [Kali] I don't know.
- Yeah.
How did this role, like,
how did it find you?
How did you find it?
How did you land in the show?
- So, "Catch The Fair One"
was my first ever time acting
and I actually helped write the film
and they were looking for
somebody to fill the role
of Navarro and Issa Lopez
and her casting director
got ahold of "Catch The Fair One".
She just wanted to basically
kind of know how I started,
what my process was.
She also, Issa involves murdered
women in a lot of her work
because she's from Mexico and Mexico City,
so there's a lot of that
epidemic going around.
So, we kind of collaborated
and just had a conversation
on what we did with "Catch The Fair One"
and what she does in her work.
And I auditioned for it,
and it was another thing where I was like,
"If it's meant for me, it'll happen."
I actually wrote...
Funny story, I wrote "I will get the part
of Evangeline Navarro in 'True
Detective: Night Country'"
over and over in my notebook,
and then I got the call!
- Project that.
- [Kali] Yes, man.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- [Kali] Yes, absolutely.
- Oh my gosh.
Well, how has being on the
show helped you highlight
what's happening with indigenous women?
Because I had no idea
until I saw this movie,
I can't remember the name,
but Jeremy Renner was in it.
- "Wind River".
"Wind River".
I had no idea, and it broke my heart.
At the end of the movie, they put like,
"This really is happening."
And I was like, "Wait, what?"
And it's such a...
A lot of people don't know,
they're just disappearing.
- Yes.
- These women are disappearing.
Like, how do you feel like
your success has honestly
had an impact on the community, right?
- I would like to think so.
I mean, with my boxing
career, I did my best
to just bring awareness to missing
and murdered indigenous people or MMIW.
It's one of those things
that help highlight
exactly what's happening
in indigenous communities.
It's not just our women,
it's our men, our women,
our boys, our elders and our
people are getting targeted.
So, it's one of those things.
Even with these earrings
with the red hand print,
anytime you see these red
hand prints on anything,
it's basically, you'll
see a red hand print
over their mouths saying
they're silencing on our voices.
So, with my boxing career,
I had an audience that didn't know,
just like you didn't know about it.
So, I would just speak about
it in front of audiences
that don't know about
it, to spread the word,
to spread awareness, to stop
this violence against women.
So, to be involved in any kind of projects
or anything to be able to talk about it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, we're just
taught to fight for those
who can't fight, speak
for those who can't speak.
- You have to talk about it.
People didn't even know.
Like, I was sitting there,
and I felt, like foolish,
and I was ashamed.
I was watching it and I
was like, "Wait, what?"
I had no idea, you know?
- It happens, it doesn't happen to just-
- [Kelly] But that's
what art is for, right?
- Exactly.
It's not just one area, it's
not just one area of America.
It's in Canada, it's any indigenous people
in anywhere in the world, you'll see
that we're targeted as a people,
but especially here in North America.
And it happens right next door.
- Yeah.
So I'm glad you're using
your spotlight for that.
- Absolutely.
- It's important.
Well, everybody be sure to check out
"True Detective: Night Country" on Max.